thank you guys so much y'all be safe
enjoy yourself i'm getting out of here
um
tom holland
i'm on your ass boy i'm on your way
do you guys do anything to make the new
cast members welcome like first time
chadwick comes on the set or first time
tom holland comes on the set any kind of
anything that goes on
tom's a little [ __ ] all right
so let's start there all right all right
time's the [ __ ] all right tell me
about spider-man why wasn't thor in that
one oh because you know it was really
for like the front-running avengers in
this movie you know it's all about kind
of yeah who's going to step up and take
rdj spot which is why i ask where was
where was thor that's why you know we
have rdj in the movie rdj is rdj tom has
his own base camp
he has like an entourage it's a lot man
he's a lot to deal with and you know
he's like
he's just a lot so you don't want to be
in the spider-man movie i have no desire
to hang out with tommy just realize that
he's not
i just got a note here says on facebook
live everybody's talking about tom's
instagram message today what did you do
i don't know what you're talking about i
i don't
you're on instagram how old are you 18
i'm not i'm 17. oh well that's why okay
all right yeah you complain about his
squeaky voice it's just a problem he's a
wildly annoying person
um
it's impressive what is annoying that's
his superpower everything because he's
so little he's like a he's like a [ __ ]
suit you know
and he's just like it's like
hey anthony yeah i'm like tom just stop
take off the spandex stop it's just it's
too much man it's too much by the way i
just want to say one this is probably
the most important thing anyone here
today tom holland has changed
you know what i will say this tom
holland is uh england's uh
hidden jewel
uh he's a phenomenal actor
um he's an amazing spider-man i feel
that was there was a reason why this
last spider-man was the most successful
one and that's 100 tom holland he brings
an energy and a vigor to that role that
you've never seen brought to spider-man
he held his own with rdj in an amazing
way that first opening sequence with him
getting the suit and being in the car is
hilarious and amazing
but he's an [ __ ]
i mean
this dude
is
awful
okay
that's all i got to say about tom hawk
it was good until tom holland showed up
with his juice boxes and
diva and his assistant he upgraded now
you said he did now
ever since the new movie came
out now he has two assistants the kid's
a bit much all right
and talk to him you know well i mean you
know he's just he's yeah he's too much
i'm like billy elliot calm down all
right it could be any other character
and you can't be yourself who would you
be okay i would be spider-man because i
can make that movie much better than
that
shots
time will you keep going just keep it
down man damn man you can't even do an
interview he over here yapping problem
are we hazing the new guy is that what
happens it's just look ever since his
movie come out he has two assistants now
yeah it's just it's so much true
get out of here man it's so much
coming from the east coast i'm a jersey
kid that accent is flawless it's
impeccable you were the first wait wait
wait you don't bother
stop
stop
there's enough of that
there's enough stuff it's a great
[ __ ] accent
who among you is least trustworthy when
it comes to the secrets uh
oh my god even the audience even they
know that
i heard that rumor too tom did you tell
them what happens
so the end of the movie no i'm not
i don't know
i remember stopping ditches yeah
now i saw the american version of that
even though we love your british news is
snitches get stitches you're right
right
batista jumps up and does like a kick
punch move
teaching him and i was like yo you're
about to kill him what are you doing
so i run over i'm like what's going on
and then you see tom try to do it and
it's like
you know
we get a comedy central roast out of
this hopefully i don't know because you
when you do a roast you do things that
aren't true this is real life this is
real life i mean he took my car
i got my car back there were no tires he
wrecked my car
the kid's a problem he has a handler
because he's like eight
and a handkerchief because he's secretly
87. is that
british it's always a pride and you
never understand what he's saying it's
like hey thomas hey
does anthony mackie like tom holland you
know what
i actually do tom holland is my friend
that's why i make fun of him i love the
kid he's a great great kid he's the best
spider-man we've had but he's an
arrogant little sh
and i i stress little
a little bite size you know how you have
the snickers down you have the fun size
now when you got the one that's so small
it's just one alphabet
it's that little [ __ ] and he has like
a size
22 waist your time
why are your pants so short oh [ __ ] i
wore my girlfriend's pants again
you what dog
when uh this is something i want and you
can be honest or not but how often are
you
in the suit because anybody could be in
the suit once they put the mask on is it
important that's a good question isn't
it tell the truth tell the truth
now and now tell the truth taking out
all the cg sequences yeah
when well just a guy standing there
talking tell the truth if it's if it's
just if there's no stunts involved it's
always me okay sometimes with some of
the stunts they are just too dangerous
to let us do them um so we have doubles
but but no but the amazing thing is
about cgi now is that we have motion
captures so all of the motion all of the
cgi stuff has been
has sort of been taken from my movement
and then put into the film
hi chris pratt i have i have a question
for mr chris pratt yes tom go right
ahead so so my question for you is um of
all the actors in the world of all of
the actors who
who is who is your favorite actor
these are people he worked with you're
talking about just anyone okay
all of them all the actors in the world
go ahead denzel
denzel washington yeah yeah he's great
no don't applaud
[Music]
anything cause i might be loving you
and i need to say
[Applause]
i'm out of my head
[Applause]
[Music]
you know me
what kinds of stuff did they do to
prevent you guys from spoiling the movie
they didn't do enough
they just gave it to tom and let him
spoil the whole thing before we could
get to it
awesome thank you guys thank you that
was pretty much it that was it they gave
him the script first and they knew he
was gonna mess it up so
by the time we got to trying to spoil it
they're like yeah we already know that
okay how do i okay what about how about
an actor whose name begins with tom
oh how about that
tom
cruise
he's great he's good top gun he's coming
out he's good he's got okay i could
simplify it for you again
what if his second name began with an h
tom h oh
thanks
beautiful day in the neighborhood yeah
that was good too it was good yeah real
good he's british
all right
he's british no
he's damaged
british come on we know who oh
he oh i see where this is going okay
we've got him now tom hardy
i forgot what my movie's called it's
called
from home spider-man far from home
that's the title spider-man far from
home yeah
spider-man is homecoming spider-man
there's gonna be a scene where he's
gonna go
i wanna go home
100p i haven't even read it i have said
that in the movie yet exactly yeah and
you said that today it was like time
sign autographs i just want to go home
try younger
but still with the
still with the tom h still with the tom
h thanks oh wow
hiddleston oh yeah
is shiri lewis going to be here yeah
yeah
[Applause]